le mois de juillet est marqué par un
événement qui a mis en joie toute la
france la victoire des bleus en coupe du
monde de football 6000 supporters se
sont rendus au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour garder
son équipe décrocher sa deuxième tranche
or autour des champions les jeunes de
l'étoile sportive de trappes ont été
conviés à l'elysée
des souvenirs un débit qui palliait
petit robot autres scènes de joie dans
les lycées les résultats du baccalauréat
les élèves en 2000 le classement de
l'académie de versailles avec un taux de
réussite les 93% le monde politique
avait les yeux tournés sur versailles le
9 juillet pour le deuxième discours du
président de la république
emmanuel macron face au congrès du
parlement dernier conseil municipal
difficile à coignières pour son maire
jean-pierre sevestre qui se termine par
une mise en demeure à son encontre après
l'été le maire élu en 2015 a finalement
présenté sa démission
11 septembre pour moi c'est la meilleure
solution parce que je considère qu'il
convient maintenant de donner la parole
aux poignets rien pour leur permettre de
peut même de choisir l'avenir de leur
ville
sereinement après préparation
d'élections
total perd donc plus tard changement
importante sur les routes au 1er juillet
le passage à 80 km heure pour les
départementale les gendarmes
evènement on fait de la prévention pour
sensibiliser les automobilistes à
villepreux ont fêté l'arrivée de l'été
en couleurs avec la première édition de
la colonne au parc du trial
attendez-vous toutes les couleurs sur le
soleil du mois d'août s'est assombri
attrape par une attaque au couteau un
homme de 36 ans poignardé trois
personnes les deux premières sa mère et
sa soeur sont mortes
le tueur a été abattu par la police une
enquête est toujours en cours
le mois de septembre a fait sa rentrée
de nombreuses personnalités politiques
sont passés par les yvelines la ministre
du travail mme muriel pénicaud est venu
inaugurer le campus de l'automobile et
des mobilités à lui en cours
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation a visité une école de poissy
faisant partie du dispositif de
dédoublement des classes
le ministre des comptes publics gérald
darmanin lui est venu parler budget face
aux événements à marly le roi enfin
marine le pen présidente du
rassemblement national a choisi mantes
la ville pour faire sa rentrée régional
chez nos élus locaux le maire de vie
preuve stéphane mirambeau rend public
son adhésion à la république en marche
je soutenir emmanuel macron dans ses
réformes je peux le pays mérite vraiment
et a besoin d'être réformé le week-end
des 15 et 16 septembre se déroulaient
les journées européennes du patrimoine à
saint quentin en yvelines une trentaine
de lieux ont ouvert leurs portes
claire public était associé dès le
départ de la création de la ville
nouvelle sur saint quentin en yvelines
la veille avait lieu le loto du
patrimoine un site yvelinois étaient
concernés la villa viardot à bougival
les gains de cette loterie exceptionnels
ont permis la remise d'un chèque de 500
mille euros pour sa rénovation
le président de la république emmanuel
macron ferrand de lui même sur place
pour la portée des moments insolites
avec nos amis les bêtes le zoo safari de
thoiry proposer son tout premier 10 km
au milieu des animaux de la savane un
événement succès qui devrait revoir le
jour en 2010 neuf fois ci s'est illustré
comme la ville de fous de ce mois de
septembre le psg a dévoilé son futur
centre d'entraînement de 74 hectares
les travaux doivent débuter durant l'été
2010 9 et le champion du monde 2018
blaise matuidi est venu inaugurer un
mini stade tout neuf à nous
l'asmi ici ici tu content le blog hors
murs mais l'événement sportif du mois de
septembre et sur un tout autre terrain
la ryder cup 2018 a jeté un coup de
projecteur sur saint quentin en yvelines
60000 spectateurs par jour se sont
rendus au golf national pour assister au
sacre de la team europe
une semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà on fût-ce à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial on
peut pas s'entraîner me bah oui oui ça
c'est c'est la fin d'une histoire mais
messi henry